oder was geht hier soll kuranyi und wir
spielen heute ein paar und pvp zusammen
mit einem lob und zwar ist dieser nun
kein geringer als soll ich jetzt mein
name sagen hey du bist du selber im
reden bis zu 1 bio ok
jona spielt ja noch nicht lange auf
seinem kanal vorbei links spielt sogar
schon ein bisschen länger minecraft ja
ich habe früher als später stimmt aber
ich habe auf jeden fall schon verrückt
so gespielt auch noch mal vor
manchmal hat jona so kleine luke moment
erst ein schwert wartete ein trennen ich
glaube rentnerin einstöckig stehen
verständigt haben
nein ich laufe ja ich bin hinter den
menschen das gefühl da war ich habe ein
herz
ja weil du nicht fähig bist ja das kommt
davon ja aber was ein schwert
ich habe mich aber ich muss ja noch
warten schaffte was wieso musst du da
warten
bis jetzt hat er noch schick aber egal
dann sehen wir uns im nächsten spiel
modus gigantisch groß würde ich sagen so
leute sind wir wieder hier spielen
diesmal wie immer mit dem unfall aber
derzeit noch nicht
heute habe ich zu viel versprochen so da
sind jetzt auch wieder wir spielen auf
der karte pyrexx und ab in die mitte
jänner geschafft wort geschafft ich
glaube die andere menschen sind auch
schon der mit freunden ist unser schönes
zeug klar aber ich glaube auch der typ
ist alleine das heißt leider nicht mehr
weil der board ist die ganze kisten ab
die hat ganz durch schlechten sachen
müssen wir auf jeden fall gut spielen
jetzt gut spielen ist sein zweiter
vorname oder jona gut spielen fischer
hast du eine dicke auch schneebälle
das noch einer dass nach einer lebte
noch ich glaube jetzt magath geschafft
habe ich mich gegeben oder sie in
giacobbo aber bisher bist du gar nicht
so kacke wie ich danke sagen hätte
er kommt jetzt ja er kommt
hast du den ich bin runter war der
alleine in seinem team
ihr könnt mich gerade wieder kommen auch
mal heraus als der schwer im kommen die
mit acht monate gestorben
natürlich gratulierten nfr direkt hinter
sich greifen als gesagt 8
ich hatte keine angst hatte ich will
dich gott
woanders war über geworden es war super
sowohl letzte das wir sagen okay der
umsatz ein glück dass nur sagen aber
kämpft sie wollte ja der hat attentäter
kitchen oder sata und er kriegt keinen
fall schaden mit dem attentäter geht das
heißt er möchte bestimmt darunter
springen gleich das ist praktisch
was echt dumm ist ja langweilig vor
abgewonnen spd runde radsport angelangt
und jona behauptet er könnte mich
besiegen bin sehr gespannt ob das der
fall ist für mich das nicht das ändern
wird
ich hab gerade vom typ der afk war nicht
mehr mit dem hart getroffen
sebastian nach ca
und wie sieht's aus wie machen was ich
will nicht gold schritt macht mich
fertig ist rau richtung zu sagen als
malermeister auch gemein zu mir dass man
diese leute dir von oben einen töten
folge meint auch das org fliegt so
scheiße
ich hab ihn nicht gesehen ich habe keine
angst überhaupt kein street parade gab
bei mir jetzt mal an magna
easy jet lag ja so richtig frech aber
liest man halo reach mode spielen nun
warum fällt an diesem modus so gerne
mögen bist du das verlieren sonst selbst
getötet damit hat sich das nun auch die
galenica für das base lutea die türen du
willst so schlecht nicht verstehst du
ich könnte diesmal nachwuchsspielerinnen
nicht bis zur zeit abläuft
ja scheiße 50 war das gerade ja sehr gut
leute und jona hast du gewonnen
leute ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
johanna war doch nicht so wie ich dachte
wenn das ganze auch für ihn gespielt
schaut einfach auf seinem kanal vorbei
stifter mittlerweile schon online sein
das video wenn ihr dieses video schaut
und bis zum nächsten mal macht's gut und
bis dahin tschüss